we're on problem 185
185 car x and car y
traveled in the same
traveled the same 80 mile route if car x
took 2 hours
so x
went 80 miles
80 miles
in two hours
and that's 40 miles per hour
miles per
hour
and car y
traveled at an average speed that was
fifty percent faster than the average
speed of car x so fifty percent faster
so y
went fifty percent faster than x so
fifty percent faster times forty miles
per hour well that's 40 plus 20 that's
equal to 60
miles
per hour
how many hours did it take car y to
travel the route
so distance is equal to rate times time
80 miles is the distance the rate is 60
miles an hour so the time
is equal to 80
over 60 which is equal to 1 and 20 over
which is equal to one and one
third hours and that's what they have
there they have choice c i thought they
might have one hour and 20 minutes
written
next problem
186.
if the average of the four numbers
k
two k
plus three
three k
minus five
and five k
five k plus 1 is 63
what is the value of k so let's just
average the numbers
k
plus 2 k
plus 3 plus 3 k
minus 5
plus 5 k plus one and that was four
numbers
so i'm gonna divide by four
and that is equal to
sixty sorry sixty three
so set up all the k's i have one k plus
two k is three k so one k plus two k
three k six k
eight k so i get eight k
and then i get three minus five is minus
two
plus one is minus one
and if you multiply the four times the
63 if we just multiply both sides of
this equation by four
you get
what 4 times 63
4 times 63 is 252.
let me think about that 4 times 60 is
240 plus 12 you have 252
and then 8k
would be equal add 1 to both sides 253
and so
k is equal to 253
divided by eight let's see what that is
eight goes into 253
it goes into 25 three times three 24.
down equals 1 time 1 times 8 is 8 you
have a remainder of 5. so it's 31 and 5
8 is k
and that is not one of the choices
let me see where i made a mistake so the
average of k
two k plus three
three k minus five and five k plus one
and that's four numbers right
and that's four numbers what is the
value of k
all right so i add up the four numbers
and i divide by four and they should be
equal to 63 so maybe i just made a
mistake in the in the
simplification so i have k plus 2k
is 3k
3k
plus 3k
is 6k oh 6k plus 5k is 11k i don't know
what i was
that's 11k and then you have 3 minus 5
which is minus 2
plus 1 minus 1. so 11k minus 1. so this
is 11k
11k and so k is equal to 253 divided by
which is
goes into 253.
see 2 times 22
33 oh that's nicer goes in exactly 23
times and that's choice
d
sorry for the error
next question 187
if p is an integer
p is even okay p even
and they're telling us q is odd
which of the following
must be
an odd integer okay so they give us a
bunch of
a bunch of things so an even times an
odd
well by definition that's going to be
even why is that well you could view it
as
this if if you multiply p times q
if p is even that means that p is
divisible by 2 right
so if 2 is one of the factors of p it's
definitely going to be one of the
factors of p times q so this one will
not be odd
let me think about it if i add an even
plus an odd
that gives me an odd
that gives me a nod so let's see if any
of the choices are that
let's see
we p divided by q an even
divided by an odd does not necessarily
and even
well this is an interesting one two p
plus q that's choice
c
now if p is even well it doesn't matter
whether p is even or not but 2p is
actually definitely going to be even
right this is going to be even and q we
already know is odd
so this is an even plus an odd so it's
going to be
odd so the choice is c and we can even
prove it a little bit if you say that p
is equal to two times some
number k right we don't know what that
is and we say that q is equal to
two times some number i don't know
m
plus one then what does this simplify to
this step simplifies to 2 times p which
is 2 times some number k we know what k
is
plus
q which is 2 times some number m plus 1
some integer m so this becomes four
times some number k
plus two times
some number m plus one
well four times some number k that's the
same thing as
that's the same thing as two times some
other number n i'm just making you know
it's two times some other integer where
n is twice of what k is right
plus two m
plus one
and this is the same thing as two times
n plus m and remember n m k these are
all just rand these are just integers
right
plus one and so if n and m are integers
then we could say well that's just equal
to two times some other integer let's
call it l plus one and this would be an
odd number right because this is even
and then you're adding one to an even
number but you didn't have to do that
you just have to recognize that an odd
plus an even is equal to an odd
choice c
next problem
drum x is one full
is one half full of oil
so x is one half full
and and drum y which has twice the
capacity of drum x is two-thirds full
so y
is two-thirds full
and has two times x capacity
if all of the oil and drum x is poured
into drum y
then drum y will be filled to what
fraction of its capacity
okay
so if x is one half full
right so
x is equal to
one half
one half of its let me think of the best
way to write this algebraically x is one
half full
which would be
and y is twice as big right so if you
poured all of this one-half into y it
would contribute to one-fourth of y's
capacity right i guess another way we
could say
we could say capacity
of x
is equal to one half the capacity of y
right so
one
so if we were to say one half the
capacity of x if we were to multiply
both sides of this by one half that's
equal to one-fourth the capacity of y
so this one-half that's equal to
one-half the capacity of x which is
equal to one-fourth the capacity of y
so if we add one-fourth of the capacity
of y to two-thirds of the capacity of y
right that's two-thirds four that's
another way of saying two-thirds times
the capacity of y
what do we get we get one-fourth
plus two-thirds
which is equal to get a common
denominator twelve
three-fourths plus 8 12
plus 8 12 right 3
3 12 plus 8 12 that's 2 3 so you get 11
12 so y would be 11 12 full of its
capacity so that is choice c
that is choice c
problem 1
if x is greater than 0
x over
plus x
over 25 is what percentage of
x
so this is equal to c get a common
denominator this is equal to over 50
x over 50 is x over 50 x over 25 is 2x
over 50 right
so that is equal to
x
over 50
which is the same thing as 3 50th
x
and that's the same thing as since we
want it as a fraction of 100 right since
we want to do a percentage that's the
same thing as if you multiply the top
and the numerator and the denominator by
2 you get 6
over 100 x
which is equal to 0.06 x which is equal
to six percent
of x and that's choice a
anyway see in the next video